that was the president United States
senile stumbling as always in this case
over the latest acronym for the pronoun
people for the record it's called
lgbtqia Plus
you see the plus Mark all over the place
now we went shopping for Mother's Day
cards today at a Rite Aid and saw an
entire category for lgbtqia plus cards
and it got us wondering who's in the
plus category are we in the plus
category we feel like we're a net
Edition we're the plus people any plus
person out there is always welcome to
come on this show and explain what's so
plus about you but in the meantime
Chadwick Moore of The Spectator has
thought a lot about this we thought we
would speak to him about it tonight Joe
thanks so much for coming on
so who's who's in the plot and look I
don't want to make this personal I don't
want to get my feelings hurt but do I
qualify in the plus category and if not
me who
oh you absolutely 100 do I mean it's
unfortunately I've been lobbying big gay
for a long time yes welcome to the
community Tucker I've been loving a big
gay for a long time
to get an s in the alphabet you know we
should have an s in there for straight
people but of course they won't let us
have that for some reason actually we
had the plus that it really you know
what they pretend to be so inclusive and
yet here they are excluding 96 of the
population uh you know but they hide it
in that plus so you can hide there in
the plot somewhere down the alphabet it
kind of signifies it much like the
struggle for justice and equality itself
the alphabet people are kind of nebulous
and extend into perpetuity they're kind
of undefinable and that is what the plus
is for anyone can be playing can I just
ask and I I think you told me once
you've been banned from gay bar since
you started coming on the show so maybe
you haven't had the experience recently
but like when was the last time you're
in a bar and someone come and said I'm
part of the I'm up I'm the plus I'm I'm
the Fable I'm the Loch Ness monster I'm
the I'm the plus you hear about but have
never seen this anyone ever said that to
you
yeah where are the minuses too like hey
I'm a plus you're a minus when we get
together tonight you know
sort of charge
I think when you start going around and
asking people if they're pluses exactly
you know one thing that's funny too is
like the cue nobody really knows what
the Q stands for I don't know either I
agree with that queer no I don't know
what it is no one knows what it is is
that really true I mean I guess we're
not you're not allowed to ask questions
you just have to sort of Nod and be like
oh yeah qia plus but what a sincere
question is someone who I think still
lives in Brooklyn like is there a real
definition for that
well I'll tell you what my definition of
queer is essentially there's two types
of queers there's the sort of runnable
Mill gay man who lives in Brooklyn you
can probably spot him by having like a
dangly earring and some really bad
eyewear uh and he calls himself queer
because he wants to feel special he
wants to think he's unique uh that's the
first type of queer the second type of
queer is really just a straight woman
who wants to add a little Pizzazz to
herself so she'll you know she thinks
she's boring she thinks she's basic she
maybe has like some gay friends she
maybe once like kissed a girl in college
so she can now call herself queer or
somewhere in the pluses but queer has
been quite quite helpful for uh for for
many people you know queer kind of does
the job of the plus anyway to be honest
not my world but absolutely fascinating
and as a believer in Precision in
language I am so grateful that you
helped us Define that tonight Chadwick
Moore thank you
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight